violence and misunderstanding will we
call on on you
on your community
you know if somebody is speaking to you
violently and saying god those muslims
they stink i wish i'll go rape their
women or why don't you go and do this or
my my very good close friend of mine she
had a hijab ripped off a couple of days
ago in leicester she's traumatized the
police did not kind of came and
questioned her husband and not the
people who did it these are real things
that really shape people so what are you
doing in your community dear viewer what
are you doing to stop the hatred when
you hear it tell us more about this what
happened now was this in the news was
this something that was just a isolated
incident that happened in your
neighborhood now or with your friend
was it something why did this happen so
she's a practicing muslim woman with
hijab
and someone just off the street randomly
came and just no they control they've
been so so they've been some bullying by
this gang of about five adults uh they
live in the same building and they've
been shoulder barging and you know
making comments was it go back to iran i
think they were saying to her some
random you know it's normally saudi
arabia i don't know why iran came up but
anyway they'd obviously read something
on the internet that day
and um so they've been bullying them and
other muslims in the block for a while
and this particular date it tipped over
and
they they pulled her hijab off and she
was actually on the ground looking for
it outside her home and her husband went
after them on his own which is dangerous
and there was a scuffle and then they
called the police they ran away laughing
they called the police and the police
questioned him
and said did you start the fight did you
do this and now they're so they're so
upset by their interactions with the
police they don't feel that they can
report it so we're still working on this
inshallah and um once you know sister's
ready uh when she's ready and charles
she will she will but this is it's a
fight brother it's a fight because
you're upset you don't feel the police
are on your side and then you've got to
get the guts to go in and see them again
and be bullied by the state
and that's that's really is this like a
group like tony robinson like the edl or
something or these are some local thugs
or just local thugs for a bit of fun bit
of a laugh
so the police i mean they're still there
she has to still see these people and
there have there haven't been any
consequences they haven't been
charged with anything not even a knock
on their door not even knock on a door
has there been public outcry some public
pressure
from that
she we've got we've got um a group
called mend and we're in touch with them
uh muslim engagement um and we're going
to be speaking to them and celebrate
hopefully uh this can get out and there
could be some more public uh pressure
isn't the uh the mayor there uh muslim
in london yeah yeah
but this is where where is this at
leicester this is the midlands there's a
couple of hundreds about 150
maybe 125 miles away
yeah but this is but here's the here's
the issue brother this is normal for
muslim women it's like oh you get
spatter and spatter never mind
it's becoming it's becoming more normal
in the uk it's getting worse rather than
better
it is what it is i've left
make no mistake i left
i left because
i'm afraid that that society is falling
apart and i wish i wish it well my
daughters are there my friends are there
my my family extended family are there
but for me as a muslim i felt it i could
it and it's not just about faith it's
not even just about ethics it's about
the the commercial material society when
you take away people's material goods
and that's what's happening now in the
uk that's what happened post covid
people fall apart and it becomes really
kind of dangerous and that um yeah
allah took me from that alhamdulillah